[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud con más romeros
a la mara bienvenida muy buen día vamos
a repasar las noticias alrededor de la
pandemia de kobe 19 como ya no es ajeno
en nuestra sección de salud
especialmente las novedades alrededor de
la vacunación contra este virus mal si
de hecho el 'new york times' sacó en
exclusiva hace poco que de pronto la
agencia del medicamento de estados
unidos la dea por sus siglas en inglés
aprobará la combinación de vacunas es
decir que una sola persona puede
vacunarse con dos tipos de fármacos
distintos para comentar todo esto y
resolver nuestras dudas estamos con
roberto de bach es de médico infectólogo
y presidente de la sociedad
latinoamericana de infectología
pediátrica buenos días doctor muchas
gracias por acompañarnos cuéntenos qué
datos tenemos alrededor de la
combinación de vacunas sabemos si serán
mejores resultados combinar dos vacunas
a en cambio vacunarse con las mismas
dosis de un solo fármaco
buenos días ya hace meses que se está
generando la evidencia en el mundo a
través de diferentes estudios estudio 11
desde inglaterra estudios desde españa y
ahora los estudios también desde los
eeuu que demuestran que la combinación
de vacunas de diferentes plataformas es
decir vacunas de arn con vacunas
vectoriales como es el caso de facer o
modernas con janssen hansen o con
janssen en sanse que también es
vectorial y con la rn pero también había
en otros otros estudios
europeos que demostraban que la
combinación entre también vacunas de
diferentes plataformas mostraban que
tenía una vacuna inmunogenicidad y tenía
una buena seguridad del mundo va a ir
por las vacunas combinadas porque las
vacunaciones heteróloga como se como se
denominan
facilitan los programas de inmunización
y el acceso a la vacuna debido a que
como países que no están accediendo a
vacunas van a poder acceder a diferentes
plataformas con iguales o con mejores
resultados
doctor los saludos muy buen día para
usted le pregunto qué ventajas puedes
tener para la campaña de inmunización la
posibilidad entonces de combinar las
vacunas de estos tipos de farmacéuticas
pero primero una cuestión inmunitaria es
decir las diferentes plataformas ya
andemos están demostrando que tienen
inclusive mejor inmunidad que las
vacunas que son de una misma plataforma
esto es esto es algo reciente el segundo
punto es que si yo puedo combinar
vacunas los gobiernos pueden comprar
diferentes vacunas y pueden implementar
más fácil los programas de vacunación
entonces esto es esto da equidad al al
mundo al acceso a imagínense que la
mitad del hemisferio norte tiene
productos brutos internos mayores y
acceden a muchas vacunas con la
reticencia que tiene el por ejemplo eeuu
del 30 por ciento pero los países del
hemisferio sur es decir en latinoamérica
y el caribe asia y áfrica no puede estar
solamente enfocados en una vacuna que
pueden comprar sino que van a tener que
depender también de entes
internacionales de ayuda en él de los
casos y entonces la mezcla de vacunas la
vacunaciones heteróloga van a permitir
un mayor acceso también desde el punto
de vista sanitario es una es una buena
noticia que definitivamente tendremos
que ver cómo sigue porque nos da una
protección más amplia el hecho de
combinar vacunas distintas no estamos
hablando de las de las vectoriales de
virus inactivado también de las de a
rené mensajero no porque nos amplía
nuestra inmunidad combinar 22 técnicas
distintas
tienen diferentes mecanismos de
presentación de lo que se llama el
antígeno lo que a la inmunidad y la
inmunidad responde de diferente manera
esta es la base racional por la cual
aparece en estas estas vacunaciones
heteróloga combinadas por supuesto todas
deberían o deben documentarse su
seguridad y si ya se están documentando
razón por la cual el factor de qué
tiene procesos diferentes y de inmunidad
responde doblemente porque lo que se
está viendo es que cuando se combinan
vacunas vuelvo a decir aumentan varias
veces la inmunidad en relación con si
hubiera utilizado el mismo fármaco
doctor deba que vuelva a preguntarle qué
pasaba con rusia no porque voy a
registrar de cosas récord de muerte de
su por covite 19 la variante delta puede
explicar este aumento de las muertes
bueno hay dos hay dos factores
aceleradores en rusia una la variante de
delta con la mayor contagiosidad y la
mayor difusión de la enfermedad y el
segundo acelerador es que rusia tiene
solamente el 30 por ciento de la
población con dos dosis o sea que hay
siete de cada diez ciudadanos rusos que
son susceptibles a la infección a una
infección de alta transmisibilidad esta
es la razón por la cual está batiendo
los récords históricos en el número de
casos diarios y el número de lamentables
fallecidos
claro de hecho recordar que ahora mismo
putin ya declaró una semana no laborable
para tratar de poner otras medidas que
no sean la vacunación puesto que no está
funcionando para evitar la transmisión
del virus no hoy fueron mil 28 muertes
en las últimas 24 horas en rusia estaba
comentando este 30 por ciento de
vacunación hay varios países de américa
latina que que también tienen umbrales
de vacunación bajos que tampoco tienen
muchas restricciones podríamos ver los
mismos estragos causados por la variante
delta o
posiblemente más tardíamente si bien la
región americana tiene caribe tiene el
35 alrededor 35 por ciento de dos dosis
administradas en su población hay países
como chile uruguay ahora argentinas que
tienen mayor tasa de vacunación pero la
la circulación de la variante delta en
la región está como retrasada o no está
causando los estragos que aparece en
otros países posiblemente haya una razón
y es que américa latina-caribe
recientemente pasó por su segunda ola la
segunda ola por ejemplo en la argentina
fue de tres millones seiscientos mil
personas que tuvieron hace hace dos
meses y esto lo que hace es que la
población esté protegida por la
infección esté protegida también por una
tasa de vacunación del 50 por ciento de
dos dosis y esto posiblemente es lo que
retrase esto no quiere decir que en los
próximos meses américa latina no se vea
enfrentada a una maduración de deltron
pues todo todo roberto gracias por su
tiempo por explicarnos entonces esta
combinación de vacunas como puede
funcionar por lo visto ya puede ser
mejor incluso combinar vacunas que tener
es sólo un tipo de vacuna de una
farmacéutica gracias por su tiempo
nuevamente por estar con nosotros en
salud de directo american france24 mar
también muchísimas gracias a ti nos
vemos mañana con más de salud